it's easy to fall in love with the place
like this for centuries ago it enchanted
European seafarers nowadays Hollywood
stars like to chill here North Island is
a small granite island in the Seychelles
that boasts one of the world's most
exclusive and expensive resorts Prince
William and his bride Kate Middleton
spent their honeymoon here it was
created after a foreign travel company
bought the island in 1997 the new owners
also turned it into a nature reserve the
main reason the island was bought was to
rehabilitate the island to what it
looked like before human settle an
island so there is a great potential for
this island to be a key biodiversity
hotspot recitals there's a high level of
biodiversity in the Seychelles and a
large number of endemic or unique native
species the people involved in
biodiversity management meet regularly
for talks in the capital Victoria along
them is a team from the United Nations
biodiversity finance initiative by ofen
it takes considerable amounts of money
and other resources to maintain and
protect nature what does it cost to
really do biodiversity conservation
effectively how do you implement
sustainable fisheries what actions do
you need every detail of that is mapped
out and costed like I can do a budget
the beauty and diversity of nature is
what draws foreign visitors 200,000 a
year tourism is the country's main
source of income the valet de my nature
reserve is a UNESCO World Heritage Site
it's a palm forest with endemic species
such as the coco de mer
it's fruits can weigh up to 25 kilos and
contain the largest seeds of any plant
in the world I get very proud when I
think of the coco de mer I think it's
it's the thing that really epitomizes
the seychelles this sense of
guardianship and respective nature are
widespread among the people of the
Seychelles it was the first state to
enshrine nature conservation in its
constitution
you